let's get ready for bed I don't like it  when you boys watch stuff like that  before bed okay so let's go come on it's  not your mom okay if it's not real do  you believe in evil something  otherworldly yes you don't stop evil  you're gonna protect yourself from it  I'm worried about Dylan why absolutely  show you there are references to big ol  across all cultures some believe that it  fed over the corruption of innocence  they were always three things in common  there's a murdered family a house in  some form of offering what is she saying  it's coordinates to where a farm where  an entire family was murdered nobody  ever comes out here that was terrible  what happened it's the kids  he gets the kids this one's right his  family's in danger  at you with me